good morning John almost every Thursday
for as far back as I can remember which
In fairness is not that far I have left
the entire day unblocked so that I can
just make a vlogbrothers video and mess
around and do it to the standard that I
want to do it and just have a good old
time it's a lovely part of my life and
right now it is 5 59 on Thursday and I
have just started and I haven't written
anything down it's been a bit of a wild
week there's just been a lot I'm not
going to get into it and I lied I have
written some words here they are I still
haven't made a video and I have no ideas
help and I posted that on Twitter and
I'm just gonna do what you say chair
ranking all right so this is chair
number one uh this is my best chair it's
the one that I sit in all the time my
mother actually painted it isn't this
beautiful we have this chair here this
is my microscope chair this one's not
that great I'm gonna give it like a 7
out of ten and then over here is my drum
throne it's a pure disaster that's the
only other chair in here I'm gonna give
it a like a zero out of ten every single
time I sit on it it falls do the format
bestie may be important for people to
know is that the format isn't easier I
mean I agree that it's fun but you still
have to like make the video you still
have to have all the words that you're
going to put into it so yeah it's going
to have a format section a format part
of it but that's it's going to be mostly
regular video Dan Lewis wants me to talk
about how Niche escalators are which he
probably knows more about than I do but
I can say that we recently lost our only
escalator in Missoula it was in the
Herbergers but then we got another one
because there's one at the new airport
so we're back baby this person wants me
to call a random number and talk to
whoever answers I'm not doing that but I
did say someone leave a phone number and
I will call you so we'll see if anybody
leaves their phone number maybe a book
recommendation video I just finished two
books that I loved a lot one was she who
became the son by Shelley Parker Chan
which was Haunting and beautiful and
kind of terrifying not like in a horror
way just in like a human way where
humans
are capable of Allah and another which I
should have read the the first eight
times someone recommended it to me but
it took me nine was children of time by
Adrian Tchaikovsky it's just chemistry
and War and space and evolutionary
biology and humans and spiders and it's
great Nicks asked if I could talk about
crash course in Spanish yeah I can we're
doing crash course in Spanish we're
starting out with my favorite of the
subjects chemistry or gimika produced in
Spanish from the bottom up writers
editors hosting all of it it's very
exciting there's only a few episodes up
so far but they will continue to come
out we are making them now I'm so
excited it's finally happening silicon
wants to see pelicans so here's a
pelican and another one and another and
another and another and another and
another and another I don't know Jake
says piezoelectric activity of bone
cells
I don't know man that sounds great is
that real bone has piezoelectric
properties because of the highly
oriented and pattern structure of
collagen and collagen's ability to
respond to Mechanical load when shearing
force is applied to collagen and they
slip past each other a piezoelectric
charge is generated what
you got an electric bones we've got
electric bones
and I didn't know that Jake Jake thank
you thank you on behalf of all of us
well John I've been recording this video
for a pretty long time now I just looked
over at the timer seems like that's
going to be four minutes of content no
problem we'll see you probably also know
about the these hankler fish that I made
for the project for awesome they're all
sold out but I did make a design based
on it and I've put it on a t-shirt it's
been a long time since I've made a
design and put it on a t-shirt I'm
excited to have done that and it's at
dftba.com if you would like it it is
there John I'll see you on Tuesday
hello hey Amy it's Hank how's it going
all right where are you at Disney world
are you a Disney World as a visitor or
as a as a a cast member as you sounded
so disappointed that you were just a
visitor I got a finish making this video
now please please don't share my phone
number with people
okay okay
thank you goodbye